and let's begin with mccarthy
and it it really is amazing to me
how there was that big buildup for
mccarthy's return
and there was a lot of anticipation
peter and we all expected the cowboys to
be pretty damn good
i picked them to be the number one seed
in the nfc
did mccarthy get a pass for last year
just because of the dak prescott injury
is it that simple of an explanation
yes but i also
think that one of the things that the
cowboys misjudged
uh you know led by mike mccarthy is how
much
of a change that defense was going to be
under mike nolan he admitted it
yesterday mccarthy did
that you know there was way too much new
stuff on defense and you know
last year i did something for my column
like i don't know five or six times
during the year
i watched in one of the zoom
squares as a position
group of some team in the nfl
was able to teach that day's process
you know and and so what was very
interesting about it is that you could
just see
a lot of the players you know in the
zoom squares
i mean it's one thing to be teaching
somebody it's like remote
learning right now in the united states
and how difficult it is it looks really
difficult to get a lot of the concepts
when a you're not in the same room with
somebody and b
you don't get to go out on the field and
practice that
after you learn it on zoom
so for the dallas cowboys to install
an entirely new defense totally new
concepts with mike nolan last year
and not get on the field till about
august 2nd
you know five weeks before you're going
to start playing football or
whatever day it was that they started
training camp
might have even been later than that you
know
like last year i'll never forget i was
in tampa at tom
brady's first time that he huddled with
his new offense
august 13th and so
to to institute and to put in a brand
new
defense the way dallas did they just
didn't have time for it and it showed
early
every week they're giving up 45 points
yeah it was the middle of august because
there was an extended break-in period
negotiated as part of
the deal between the league and the
union it allowed things to restart amid
the pandemic because guys hadn't done
anything
they wanted to slowly get them
acclimated before they got on the field
so you're right it was the middle of
august for most teams before they
actually
got on the field you mentioned the
defense i want to listen to some of what
mccarthy said about the defense i have
some thoughts
about the failures from last year and
why maybe we didn't expect them
after we hear what he has to say here he
is from yesterday
the focus of change would definitely be
on the defense so
obviously with the change in you know
the coordinator and the coaches
um you know we feel uh the direction
that
where i see the team needs to get goes
is going to come under leadership with
dan quinn
you know i've known dan for quite some
time and you know having a chance to
to be in position to hire him uh
is definitely a you know an asset huge
asset to our
to our football operations so and
you know schematically uh to the to the
naked eye
or layman's you know terms i mean i
don't think we'll see
a whole lot uh because i think it's
important to
to build off of what we did accomplish
there to probably the second eight weeks
you know our ability to take the ball
away and there was probably some
you know conceptual things i felt like
our players really
really understood and played fast with
which wasn't evident in the first eight
weeks so
you know we're not throwing this isn't a
start over situation we're able to build
off of
some of the things we accomplished last
year so that's that's definitely
was part of my thinking and uh you have
the opportunity to hire dan and
i really like the way the staff has come
together uh you know it's
the energy and enthusiasm i think the
diversity of
some of the assistants so it's an it's
an opportunity for improvement
and i think we're definitely on the
right path there
beyond the changes in coaches they've
added some players safety
ken o'neal and damonte cassie on the
team now but peter i'm conflicted on
this
miles simmons and i talked about this on
pftpm last night on one hand i want to
give the cowboys credit for recognizing
that it wasn't working under mike nolan
and making the change on the other hand
i want to indict the cowboys
for hiring mike nolan in the first place
for not recognizing the depths of the
changes that would be necessary
when you bring in a new system and your
personnel maybe doesn't match it
and why aren't you working harder to get
people like
us to understand it so we can help
spread the message of reducing
expectations because once we got into
september we saw
about the defenses we were all kind of
caught flat-footed and we all
i think had the same realization at
about the same time
well what did we expect with mike nolan
coming in with completely new defense
like the cowboys did nothing to get
people to understand this wasn't going
to be
the 85 bears right out of the gates not
that anyone expected that
but we didn't expect him to be that bad
and i think that that points to failure
in a lot of different ways by the
cowboys that it was so bad
and that it caught us by such a surprise
and now here they are bottoming out
after a year and changing coordinators
and mccarthy's only been there for one
season
mike i think the biggest thing is that
obviously
you know mike nolan was hired and
all of these plans were made when
everyone from jerry jones on down
thought that they had a full
off season to institute them and so
you know there's probably no single unit
in the nfl last year that suffered more
because of the effects of the
coronavirus
on the united states than the dallas
defense
and i think when you sort of go
back and do an autopsy on the dallas
season
i think right away what what i have
thought
right away is that the cowboys should
have recognized
how revolutionarily different this
defense was going to be for them
and they should have said well look we
don't have
time this year hopefully next year we'll
be able to get everybody on the field
and we'll continue
the installation of this defense but
honestly
they just tried to do too much in one
off season that wasn't
an off-season it was an off season
and that's where i think the problem
lies
great point why does mike nolan pay for
it with his job then if there's a
perfectly good explanation
for why it went so sideways last year
why is nolan out why aren't they
building on
what they did we heard that sense
from mccarthy that they're not
completely
revolutionizing the defense now it's not
a full rebuild they're building on some
of the things that went well last year
that's where i'm confused because what
you said makes sense
but then i can't reconcile that with
firing nolan after one season mike it
it had to be it had to be that they lost
faith in mike nolan
perhaps not just the installer and
teacher but in mike nolan the coach and
his ability to reach the players
if he had had this tremendous
uh you know simpatico with these guys as
they're going through this
horrible time and then as they rally
later in the year to be better
as they simplified it a little bit it
would be one thing
and they would say okay mike uh you're
coming back this offseason and we're
gonna continue to get better blah blah
blah
but obviously mccarthy the the
administration
saw things that they simply didn't like
and
what those specific things are i don't
know but
i agree with you if they're playing
better
later in the year it's easy to stand up
after the season and say you know
we tried to do too much this year and
we're going to finish the job this
coming off season
uh but we're going to go forward with
what we have so there's got to be
something else there
you had done some reporting on
mccarthy's planning during his year off
his buyout year with the packers and it
seemed very meticulous
and basically he set up a football
laboratory in wisconsin
and he had things planned out ahead of
time as to what he was going to do
was nolan his first pick heading into
getting his next nfl opportunity or was
nolan a guy that
just kind of happened to be available in
that game of musical chairs that gets
done when coaches are trying to fill out
staffs
that's a good question mike uh mike
mccarthy did not
uh i didn't really press him on it but
he didn't talk about
his coaching staff plan
uh in fact if you if i had to guess
leaving there
whatever it was now 16 months ago
leaving his house when it was
eight below zero in green bay one
december afternoon
uh i would have guessed that jim haslet
was going to be his defensive
coordinator but
uh that wasn't the case so i don't know
how he ended up i know that
he's had a long relationship with mike
nolan going back obviously
to when uh mccarthy was on nolan's staff
obviously when they drafted alex smith
in 2005
um but i don't know if he was his first
choice
or if there are other choices along the
way
as to dan quinn when you think about his
experience and
specifically the fact that he's never
been a defensive coordinator
for an offensive coach who would like to
just hand the keys over
quinn got the job in atlanta inheriting
a system that had been crafted by pete
carroll
not nearly the same as a bill belichick
who was a defensive mastermind
and he was the guy for pete carroll in
seattle he's the mastermind and the
revolving door of coordinators who kept
getting head coaching jobs from gus
bradley then to
dan quinn and then there was thought
chris richard would be the next one that
never really worked out but
but quinn wasn't that
defensive guru with any one team and
then he becomes a head coach
and now he's really a coordinator for
the first time where
it looks like he's gonna be the guy
who's in charge of that side of the ball
do we have confidence especially when we
look at how the falcons
uh have done they haven't been great
defensively
under him do we think that this is going
to suddenly be a much better defense or
should we have tempered expectations
this year
just like we should have had them last
year
and mike i hate to uh go back on exactly
what happened last year but i do
think that some of this is going to be
uh dependent on what sort of offseason
do they have
okay and if the off season is relatively
normal
then what's gonna happen if if you if
you've been around dan quinn for any
length of time
and you've got to be a person of a
certain age to know what i'm about to
say but
he's the norman vincent peale of nfl
coaches
he is the power of positive thinking and
he is going to convince
mediocre players whether they are or not
that they are fantastic and we're gonna
have the best defense in the league
for you know for two or three
consecutive years
you know i would go into atlanta during
training camp
and i'd sit with uh dan quinn and it's
so
kind of ironic the signings that they
have because
he believed fervently
that keanu neil was going to be the
biggest difference making safer
safety hybrid linebacker in the nfl
he thought basically he was going to be
what we saw
on many occasions jamal adams to be over
the last couple of years
and you know keanu o'neal has never been
quite that entire package
that jamal adams was but what he's going
to do
is he is going to convince his players
every one of them
of how great they are in the great
things that they can do
and you know he's the kind of guy who
he believes that if he has seen demarcus
lawrence
you know pull a great swim move on
a great offensive tackle one time
that they can train him and coach him to
do it every time
so that is what the cowboys are getting
in dan quinn
and that confidence and optimism really
permeates the entire nfl this time of
year when everyone is zero and zero and
no one has to play a game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports